hello and welcome to the next breakout
session in security
in this session we take you through a
deep dive in solving a critical but
often hard to accomplish
security objective of least privilege my
name is avi yada
i'm a product manager at google for
identity and access management
and today i'm excited to share with you
google's latest innovation in
iem called policy intelligence and
joining me today is a brilliant panel
first we have vandy who's a product
manager and researcher at google working
in policy intelligence
hi mandy hi abby
hi everyone
and later joining us is dianne blackaire
who's a certified expert in google cloud
and also the lead architect at violia
an organization with more than 170 000
employees
and he will walk us through some of the
olia's advanced tooling and journey in
achieving least privilege in the cloud
now when i think of the cloud i
sometimes think
of this airplane cockpit but the cloud
probably has
more knobs and dyes than this cockpit
does
it is well complicated so some customers
like violia have
tens of thousands of projects in the
cloud and these resources get spun up
and down faster than the security teams
to keep up with them
add to this multiple layers of policy
control and you have a rather complex
security environment
and even if you have the right
information it's fairly difficult to
know if you've made the right decision
so as a result in this environment
maintaining least privilege is often a
challenging and never-ending task
where failure can have pretty high
consequences
so at google we ran a study of our
customers and found that 95
of permissions that were given were
never used so over provisioning is a
real
common problem and a threat when
somebody
you think should just have read access
also has the ability to take down
production
and there are several factors causing
this there's a lack of visible
visibility into understanding how well
policies are configured
understanding effective access
effectively weak governance and
oversight that leads to practices like
model after that go unchecked
and the elastic nature of cloud that
makes it more difficult to audit
often leading to carryover access from
previous assignments
now ideally you want to construct your
policies in a way
that you reach a state of measurable
leased privilege
where you limit the attack surface by
granting users only the permissions they
need at the time they need it
but we've seen that customers often
hesitate about changing their policies
because they don't want to break
anything but this exposes them to risk
and you know generally people tend to
underestimate the risk they're in
i think it's just human nature so our
goal here in this entire area is to give
you
a better understanding of the policies
you have and to help you manage them at
scale
so you can balance the trade-off between
security and developer velocity
after all you know our customers come to
us tell us that the promise of cloud is
that we shall make your security better
just like ours
so we want to help you understand where
you are exposed
and how you can design better so you
don't get breached
so if you are a security professional
concerned about this
like steve here here is some practical
and prescriptive guidance from google on
how you should think about achieving for
lease privilege
so steve needs to ensure that access is
appropriate to business
need and have you know reach a goal at
the end where policy management is
scalable it's timely and effective so
let's look at some of steve's challenges
in blind spots
first how does steve just define what is
appropriate access
to begin with he needs to know what
users have access to today
then to scope it down what's safe to
remove
steve could do this through you know
trial and error but that's time
consuming
and how do you know what users will need
in the future
secondly how do you get a good
understanding of risk
without being an expert in google cloud
of course so steve is concerned about
buckets being exposed to the
internet or the risk of a service
account being misused for lateral
movement
over grounding can also be caused by
simple unintentional human error
that can also result in data loss or
infrastructure changes that are often
hard to revert
now after you solve all these problems
how do you change your policies in a way
that is safe so it doesn't break
anything in production
and that scales so that steve and you
can do this uniformly across the
organization using code
and lastly steve needs to make sure that
this is measurable
so he can report back that he is moving
the organization towards least privilege
now all of this is obviously much easier
said than done
at google we believe that hiring and
solving this problem by just hiring and
staffing cyber security experts in
today's world
is not a scalable solution to these
problems we believe the answer lies
in intelligence and automation and so we
built our product
policy intelligence to assist users as
they move through the life cycle
of policy management to manage these
policies securely and with confidence
and we do this by fusing the magic of
google which is data
machine learning throughout your cloud
experience
a way to think about this is think about
the way cars have evolved
today's cars kind of seem like the car
on the left it's
manual and unguided and we want to
upgrade the experience like
modern cars and beyond with it with the
help of tools that we provide
to make your security much better so we
want to effectively take policy
management through this
same upgrade to achieve intelligence and
automation
like we did with cars so we asked
ourselves
what can we do to empower our customers
in this way
and after speaking with many of you we
found that the answers were clearly in
three areas
first you want to find out what went
wrong quickly so you can take action
right away with
troubleshooting tools secondly
you want to prevent mistakes from
happening altogether with analytical
tools
and thirdly you want to improve your
cloud easily with actionable
recommendations
now to talk to you and walk you through
these products in detail
i'll hand it over to bandy for a deep
dive
thanks abby so let's start with policy
troubleshooter
we designed it to make it super easy for
you to understand
why a user doesn't have access when
you're in the midst of doing something
it's frustrating to see an error message
and not know what to do next
especially when you expect your policies
have been set up correctly
this might seem like a simple issue but
it can be surprisingly hard to
troubleshoot
without troubleshooter you'd have to
scan all the policies
across the hierarchy one by one you'd
have to find the policy that allows api
call
and if that policy has a group you need
to manually check
if the user is in the group all of this
takes a lot of time
and our customers don't want security to
be in the way of productivity
so admins like steve would usually
unblock their developers
by granting them overly permissioned
roles just so they're not blocked
now with self-service tools like policy
troubleshooter
a developer can hit troubleshoot when
they see an error message
and share the url of the troubleshooter
to steve
the error message automatically passes
the principal
resource and permission
policy troubleshooter will show you all
the relevant policies across the
hierarchy
so admins like steve can make a decision
on the best place to grant the developer
access it helps steve understand
which roles are needed to unblock this
developer
and also helps you make decisions on
where in the hierarchy to grant roles
at times a user might even be blocked
because they're not a member of the
right group
and troubleshooter can help help you
figure this out
troubleshooter also highlights dynamic
access control issues
such as when conditions are applied for
example
a developer might get an error if she
accesses a resource after 5 pm
and troubleshooter will easily tell
steve the issue
is the user did not meet the time
condition
with policy troubleshooter steve now
feels that he's in a position
to not only establish the principle of
least privilege
but actually maintain it instead of
simply granting
overly permissive roles to everyone who
comes to him with
my access isn't working type of issues
so here are some ways you can use policy
troubleshooter
if you're not sure if a service account
that is buried in a group
can reach a resource troubleshooter will
show you group membership
even for nested groups designed as an
admin self-service tool you can
integrate this into your help desk tools
like jira
and we're excited to announce we're
extending this to support vpc service
controls
and identity aware proxy errors
while steve was troubleshooting for his
developer he was surprised to see owner
roles assigned on his project
so policy analyzer is our query tool
that can help you reduce your
organizational risk
through improved visibility if you're
looking to understand
who has access to what what does that
access secure
and what are users doing with that
access you can do so
efficiently with policy analyzer
steve quickly uses policy analyzer to
find out who has the owner role in his
organization
and where it was granted he selects the
owner role
and does the query in the results
steve can now see members who have this
role
with policy analyzer steve is able to
answer this question
and many more in addition to this one he
had in mind
he runs a couple of other queries which
vms can john delete
who has right access on this bigquery
data set
it feels like magic
if you're wondering how someone's access
will change when they move from one
group to another
use policy analyzer to understand access
impact
also use it to query and create reports
for privilege
escalation and access certification
and if you're wondering what changed in
a policy and when
use policy analyzer to understand the
history of your policies
but before steve changes the order role
he wants to make sure he doesn't break
anything
with policy simulator steve can check
the proposed policy changes
against the 90-day access history of the
user
to see if the changes would block any
essential access
that was previously used steve knows
anita often works in bigquery so he
changes anita's owner role to bigquery
admin
policy simulator shows which permissions
would have been newly granted with the
bigquery admin role
and which permissions would be revoked
with policy simulators results
steve can assess the impact of the
change and ensure
anita's productivity is not impacted
these analytical tools like
troubleshooter analyzer
and simulator can help you figure out
what your current state of policies are
then we have tools like the recommender
to give you proactive guidance on how to
achieve least privilege
and to tell you about this i'll hand it
back to abi thank you vandy that was
great
so we introduced im recommender last
year at next
2019 to help customers achieve least
privilege with least effort
and since then we are super excited that
thousands of customers around the world
are using this every day to minimize
their tax surface
now this product helps security and
non-security professionals
identify unneeded access to gcp
using machine learning we provide smart
access control recommendations
right here in the iem page the
recommender is going to show you how
many permissions
are given and how many are actually
being used there's no need to collect
and pass through activity logs
we've done all that hard work for you in
the back end we store and process
petabytes of log data daily at no
additional charge to our customers
we now simply show you this data and
these results right here next to the
user's role assignment now it looks like
most of the members in my project here
are okay there are few that are using a
lot less than were granted
and you can see three light bulbs have
popped up this is where our ml models
have found a recommendation for a better
fitting role
auto magically in the background i had
to do no work
now this service account on the top row
has owner role with about 1800
permissions assigned
but it has used only 31 of them so now i
am recommender
is going to tell me that i should change
its role to reduce the attack surface
and if i need i can click to get more
details
so here the tool shows me the analysis
behind the recommendation
it suggests the service account should
be moved to the bigquery admin role
and why by highlighting the permissions
here that are safe to remove in red
now ml also picks up that this account
would mean the saved queries
update permission in the future based on
similar usage patterns
now this is the permission it already
has but it has not yet used
and you can find this mark everywhere
with the blue ml icon
so this this we do this because we want
to make sure that users or service
accounts don't miss out on permissions
and don't have to come back later to
request more
and now in our latest update we have
also added the ability for you to
customize the recommendation
if you want to remove a permission or
add one you can do that
right here in the recommendation screen
in context
which creates a custom role and now your
custom role will be based on actual
activity data
and improved with google ml to suggest
which permissions you need to add
based on observed patterns in the cloud
so you just need to hit
apply and that will make the change
creates the custom role
and assigns it to the service account
and now this custom role will be
recommended to other members as needed
another area where we have invested in
this year is making recommendations
easier to discover
so project teams can self serve in the
cloud in the cloud console
in the iem page as we have shown you
already now they can also find
recommendations in our recommendation
hub
that is located in the cloud console
dashboard
here project teams can review their
insights and the recommendations
and apply them if they have the
permission secondly
for central security teams we now
support out-of-the-box
integration with bigquery so with a few
simple steps you can export all your
recommendations to a bq table
now this will allow you to create
org-wide custom reports
so for example if you want a view of
over provisioning across your production
workloads
or if you want to analyze a given
permission for a service account
you can do that very easily here with
using our analytical tools
and lastly we expose insights and
recommendations
through apis with methods such as get
claim marker succeeded
so in addition to automating
recommendations
we've also had some customers use this
to create alerts and reminders
so they're sending weekly digest to
their project teams
alerting them that they should take
action
so here are some ways that you can get
started with im recommended today
number one to protect against lateral
movement
we recommend a defense in depth strategy
a key piece of this approach
includes limiting members who have the
act as permission on projects
as well as service accounts so you can
use im recommender to ensure
that users are not assigned the service
account user role
at the project level also you can use
recommended to understand
where service accounts have permissions
across projects
so for example if a service account that
is in project a
has been granted a role in project b you
can use recommender to understand
where these can be removed to mitigate
lateral movement threats
secondly just don't use owner and editor
legacy roles
these are not recommended and you can
use im recommender today
to scope down the access to more
granular roles
our product now provides a migration
path from these legacy roles to more
to multiple and smaller roles which is
best practice so you can go from a large
owner roll to more fine grain rolls
and lastly as we saw earlier you can use
this feature to create
meaningful custom roles based on
activity data
actual activity data and machine
learning
and lastly let's share with you some pro
tips if you have
like many of our customers thousands of
projects and recommendations
to start with developing a
prioritization strategy in a framework
to identify the severity of these
recommendations in the context of your
cloud environment
so you can understand which ones you
want to apply first
think about exporting these
recommendations to your existing
iga or access certification tools and
this would help speed up your resource
owner or user manager certifications
and you can use these recommendations
with with insights
to understand what access a user has
across projects
and lastly when using our apis don't
forget to mark recommendations as
succeeded
as when you have applied them this will
help you track your progress towards
least privilege
so now i'm super excited to introduce vm
to talk about violia's journey in using
policy intelligence to achieve least
privilege
violia is one of google cloud's
largest customers in the world they have
been using it for a long time and they
have thousands and thousands of projects
and they've also been providing us
feedback from early stages and have been
an advocate in shaping the direction of
our products thank you bm
thank you abby hello everyone i'm
guillermo blackaire
i'm google developer expert on cloud
platform
and schoolmaster and lead architect at
failure
veria is a french company present in 50
countries
with more than 177 employees
our mission is to resource the world
yes that's all to resolve the world
quite normal for an environmental
company
focused on three main businesses water
waste and energy we have been using
google cloud
for more than seven years our footprint
is large
with more than eighty seven seven
projects
more than our absolute projects
and actually we have almost five
thousand
cloud projects thousands of engineers
external and internal employees are
currently working
on the platform
at the beginning seven years ago our
teams were unsure about using google
cloud
and they were mostly playing in it
today it has become the new normal and
our team have worked to reduce friction
and improve security that increase
confidence in building in gcp
secondly for us creativity is a
competitive differentiator
so we want to let developers build and
not put constraints on them
the security team's goal is to manage
any risk without blocking these
developers
from building
in seven years our understanding of risk
has improved
while we used to give owner an editor
hold to accounts
service accounts and user accounts
we are now moving away from this as an
example of releasing lists
on the other hand google groups is a
real problem for us
two minis with high privilege role where
any user account can be added and so
we don't have visibility into risk
asking project team to choose the right
role is confusing to them
and they don't take time to search and
test
which role are best we tried
educating our user but
we found that to be difficult so now
we want to prevent the bad things from
happening
and teach developers what the good
outcome look like
so where to start and how to do that
the first step is to clean up existing
project in production
yes in production because it's critical
with access to sensitive data
for this we have been using i am
recommender
in the google ui to view and apply the
recommendation
the central security team in paris my
team
does this cleanup in coordination with
the project manager
to be sure the application continues to
run as expected
we started with small projecting
production not the most critical
and we applied without hesitations or
recommendation
after successful results on few projects
we expanded this to more than 100
critical projects in production
this clean up was one time and took four
months
we found these recommendations to be
safe they had no impacts in production
no incident happened which was great
after this cleanup we shred any reversal
to the bloodhole
bindings as a security incident
to detect this we use security command
center's
real-time notification to process
primitive role
findings we log them into slack
we send an email to the project owner
and we open an incident
in servicenow the communication
by slack and email leads to the step 3
and did and to discuss the incident with
a project owner
we explain why highly privileged role is
not needed
and how to secure i am policy
we use this opportunity to educate them
on best practices
during the discussion we use a policy
simulator
to show the project owner the impact of
the change in production
if the project owner doesn't know which
hole to assign
or doesn't trust the simulator no
problem
we leave the incident open mark as
observed
and after 90 days we will automatically
apply the recommendation
from imre commander by api
finally to get a company-wide picture of
risk
we took the findings data in bigquery
and put
that in data studio to understand which
teams are doing
well and where the risk lies
to drive cultural change we would like
to identify
country by country which teams are
adopting
best practices then
we should develop a roadmap to address
this risk
with each country we plan to visit them
and
educate them further
so we launched a cleanup exercise
as shown in step 1 in the previous
process
last year this was very successful
our primary goal was to reduce
permissions
on production projects we started slowly
in october
took time to validate the impact in
production
then we planned a huge prediction before
christmas
and the rest in january
we were able to show and remove over 1
million permissions
this number was surprisingly
we knew that we weren't perfect on the
security side
but we were surprised and happy to see
we were able to close so many security
gaps
quickly in summary
we had no issue after applying the
recommendations
they were safe sims are more responsive
when we show
them data from policy intelligence and
because the data is completing it's easy
for us
to make changes the next step for us
is to apply these recommendations
automatically
any time on all projects
so after working on this the most
important thing for me as a security
team member
is trust i chose the data from
recommender
it took some time to learn about it but
now
i fully trust all the results coming
from it
i would like to thank the policy
intelligence team
for working with us thank you for
listening
thank you for sharing that diane it's so
lovely to see customers like violia who
use
these tools in such interesting ways so
we're very excited to announce that
policy intelligence
is now part of active assist a brand new
solution from google cloud
active assist is a solution that focuses
on reducing complexity in your cloud
environment
and providing you with a variety of
intelligent and proactive features
many of which are based on machine
learning by using the capabilities of
active assist
you are empowered to focus more on your
business and less on cloud
administration
active assist offers capabilities for
members across multiple ide teams
whether it's compute and storage or
networking or security like us
and cost and billing management etc etc
by using active assist your teams can
use the capabilities to help them do
many things like
reducing and minimizing waste by
provisioning vms precisely or realizing
discounts fully
elevating your security posture with
tighter permissions
and clear and functional firewall rules
and minimizing toil across the board by
identifying and fixing issues
rapidly and testing configurations
before you commit them
all of which frees up time savings and
more important endeavors for you to
change like
business innovation a long story short
active assist is here too well actively
assist you
and we want to help you focus on your
goals by using intelligence and
automation to vastly reduce the time
you spend on cloud administration now if
you'd like to learn some more
check out our new website at
cloud.google.com
activeassist and attend our two breakout
sessions cmp100
and if you'd like to learn more about
iem recommender in a deep dive session
attend our breakout session sec 216.
thank you very much for your time we
hope you enjoyed this session today and
happy ironing